UKRAINE.
PUTIN'S WAR AND OTHER REPUBLICA-
I'M TRACE GALLAGHER.
NOW BACK TO "HANNITY."
>> Sean: JOE JOE BIDEN'S WORK
BORDER CRISIS GOING FROM BAD TO
WORSE.
THERE HAS BEEN A WHOPPING
1 MILLION MIGRANTS IN JUST THE
LAST SIX MONTHS.
ACCORDING TO FAILED DHS
SECRETARY MAYORKAS, THE CRISIS
BEING EFFECTIVELY MANAGED.
REALLY?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE INHERITED A BROKEN AND
DISMANTLED SYSTEM THAT IS
ALREADY UNDER STRAIN.
IT IS NOT BUILT TO MANAGE THE
CURRENT LEVELS AND TYPES OF
MIGRATORY FLOWS, ONLY CONGRESS
CAN FIX THIS.
YET WE HAVE EFFECTIVELY MANAGED
AN UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
NONCITIZENS SEEKING TO ENTER THE
UNITED STATES AND INTERDICTED
MORE DRUGS AND INTERCEPTED MORE
SMUGGLING OPERATIONS THAN EVER
BEFORE.
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS WILL STRAIN
OUR SYSTEM EVEN FURTHER AND WE
WILL ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE
SUCCESSFULLY.
>> Sean: INHERITED?
ARE YOU KIDDING?
THEY CAUSED ALL OF THIS.
WHAT THEY INHERITED WAS THE MOST
SECURE BORDER WITH THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IN
A LONG TIME.
AND GET THIS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NOW WILL BE
FORCED TO COMPLY WITH A
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER
GRANTED BY A LOUISIANA JUDGE
WHICH BLOCKS THE LIFTING OF
TITLE 42, SENATE DEMOCRATS, YOU
KNOW, BORDER STATES, ARIZONA,
NEVADA, TEXAS, ARE IN YET
ANOTHER ELECTION YEAR CONVERSION
ON THE BORDER AS THE BIDEN OPEN
BORDERS CATASTROPHE IS
DESTROYING AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY,
THREATENING U.S. NATIONAL
SECURITY AND UNLEASHING NOTHING
BUT CHAOS ON BORDER STATES.
OUR VERY OWN SARA CARTER BACK
DOWN AT THE BORDER THIS WEEK
WITH MORE EXCLUSIVE REPORTING,
SHE JOINS US NOW WITH HER
INVESTIGATION.
YOU KNOW, JUST WHEN YOU THINK,
SARA, IT CAN'T GET ANY WORSE,
HERE IT IS, WE ARE NOW HEADED
FOR ANOTHER RECORD OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE COUNTRY.
WE ALREADY SET ONE.
>> YEAH, SEAN, IT IS GETTING FAR
WORSE.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER, BUT ABOUT THE
NUMBERS OF LIVES LOST, AND WHILE
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS WAS BEING
GRILLED BY CONGRESS, WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH BORDER PATROL
CHIEF RAUL ORTIZ WHO WAS DOWN ON
THE FRONT LINES OF EAGLES PASS
WITH HIS AGENTS, WATCHING THE
SITUATION EVOLVE AND WARNING
THAT IT IS GOING TO GET FAR
WORSE BEFORE IT CAN EVER GET
BETTER.
LISTEN TO THE SPIRIT >> IF YOU
HAVE A MESSAGE FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TEMPING TO CROSS, YOU
NEVER KNOW, THEY COULD BE
WATCHING THIS, AND THEY DO, WHAE
TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING
SMUGGLED ACROSS THIS RIVER -- IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT COULD GET
THEM TO STOP?
>> DON'T PUT YOUR HANDS IN THE
LIVES OF THE SMUGGLERS, THEY
LOOK AT THESE IMMIGRANTS AS A
COMMODITY, THEY'RE NOT TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION THIS IS HUMAN
LIFE AND THEY ARE GOING TO PUT
THEM IN DANGEROUS CONDITIONS.
WHETHER IT IS CROSSING THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER AT NIGHT WITH
SMALL CHILDREN, OR WHETHER IT IS
PUTTING THEM IN A TRAIN CAR OR
TAKING THEM OUT TO THE DESERT
AND LEAVING THEM ABANDONED SO
SEARCH PARTIES HAVE TO GO OUT
AND RESCUE THEM.
THERE IS A LEGAL PROCESS TO SEEK
ASYLUM AND WE HOPE THAT MORE OF
THESE MIGRANTS TAKE THAT PROCESS
UNDER ADVISEMENT AND
CONSIDERATION.
>> AND SEAN, ON THAT DAY THAT WE
SPOKE, TO CHIEF ORTIZ, THEY
RECOVERED THE BODY, TEXAS DPS
RECOVERED THE BODY OF SPECIALIST
BISHOP EVANS WITH THE
NATIONAL GUARD FROM ARLINGTON,
TEXAS, WHO SELFLESSLY GAVE HIS
LIFE ATTEMPTING TO SAVE THE
LIVES OF TWO MIGRANTS WHO ARE
NOW BEING HELD IN FEDERAL
CUSTODY PENDING AN INVESTIGATION
BY THE TEXAS RANGERS.
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS
SITUATION AND THE WARNING FROM
CHIEF ORTIZ GOES OUT TO
EVERYONE: STAY OUT OF THE
RIO GRANDE.
DON'T CROSS THAT RIO, IT IS
DEADLY AND IT IS DEADLY FOR
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER, SEAN.
>> Sean: AND MAYORKAS ADDED
THE BIGGEST THREAT TO AMERICA IS
DOMESTIC TERRORISM?
>> IT'S INCREDIBLE, I CAN TELL
YOU A LOT OF AGENTS HAVE BEEN
STUNNED BY HIS STATEMENT, I HAVE
BEEN ON THE PHONE WITH I.C.E.
OFFICERS AS WELL AS BORDER
PATROL AGENTS WHO REALLY CANNOT
BELIEVE WHAT ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS
IS SAYING, AND MANY OF THEM HAVE
CALLED FOR HIS RESIGNATION, SO
THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
END HERE AND LAWMAKERS ARE
CERTAINLY GOING TO CONTINUE TO
CHALLENGE HIM AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IN THE UPCOMING
MONTHS.
>> Sean: AND ADMIRE TO THE
LIST OF ADJECTIVES FOR MAYORKAS
BECAUSE H